Life on earth depends
on a Goldilocks climate
- not too hot and not too cold.
Humankind is changing that.
Industrialisation has raised
temperatures around 1 degree.
Experts think a further
rise of another degree
is possible by 2052, even
after big emissions cuts.
Crops will be more
likely to fail,
displacing human populations.
In Paris in 2015,
industrialised nations
agreed they would limit global
warming to less than 2 degrees
above pre-industrial levels,
but there has been more hot air
than action.
Nations cannot agree how much
each should cut emissions.
Rising populism has
fostered scepticism
about global warming.
Under Donald Trump,
the US has threatened
to withdraw from
the Paris accord.
They have a collective
action problem.
Everyone would benefit from
cutting emissions, eventually.
No one wants to be
the prime mover.
So there is no progress.
The reason is that the
costs of global warming
remain an externality
for most individuals.
There is no immediate
benefit in reducing them.
As a result, impacts
are an externality
to most politicians,
too, except when
protesters from
Extinction Rebellion
disrupt the traffic, as
they did recently in London.
They are preoccupied
with getting
elected every few years.
It is, as they sometimes
say in business, NMP,
or next management's problem.
By the same logic as
temperatures rise,
people will start
bearing direct costs.
For example, some populous
parts of the world
will become too hot to
inhabit in the summer
or to visit as tourists.
The facts such as these will
create an electoral incentive
to slash emissions.
Then nations will
start taking action.
Squabbling will continue.
One flashpoint will be
output of polluting coal.
This is expected to peak at well
over 8bn metric tonnes in 2030.
Many in China and India see
western demands for production
cuts as self-serving.
Even within developed nations
there will be conflicts.
US researchers have predicted
hefty economic damage
to Texas and Florida
later this century,
coupled with more modest
benefits for the states
of Washington and Oregon.
What will the consequences
be for investors?
The value of big oil companies,
such as Royal Dutch Shell,
would fall.
If reserves cannot be
exploited fully they need to be
discounted heavily.
The value of renewables
groups, like Denmark's Orsted,
would go up reflecting
a growing market.
Their technologies would depend
less and less on subsidies
to make profits.
Nuclear generation
would make a resurgence
as a supplier of
baseload electricity.
That would bolster
the price of uranium,
which has been depressed
since the Fukushima disaster.
Extreme weather would
become more common.
That would make farming
investment riskier,
but agricultural commodities
trading more lucrative.
Demand for catastrophe
insurance would
continue to rise sharply,
bolstering Lloyd's of London
and the market for
catastrophe bonds.
Some competing companies
appear more committed
to a low-carbon economy
than competing nations.
JPMorgan estimates
three-fifths of car sales
would be hybrids or
fully electric by 2030.
That compares with
2 per cent in 2015.
Lex believes big traditional
carmakers, such as VW and GM,
will succeed in
switching wholesale
into electric vehicle output.
They understand mass
production, after all.
That will leave Tesla where it
is now, as a niche business,
if it is not bought out.
Another interesting niche will
be hydrogen fuel cell vehicles.
Toyota has made a
side bet these will be
needed for hauling heavy loads.
The reason?
Growth in the weight-to-power
ratio of batteries
has been linear.
Exponential growth
would be needed
for battery-powered vehicles to
become universal, experts say.
Businesses will need to make a
lot of other intelligent bets
to build the low-carbon economy.
Governments will belatedly
impose the incentives
and penalties needed.
The one certainty
of climate change
is that business as usual
will not be an option.